we're like dragging my feet now what
what happened in this the fight where
you lost the title where your leg gave
out I stepped back rolled the ankle
pinched that nerve and then my foot just
went straight so from rolling the ankle
that's when that's what did it that's
what pinched a nerve did you see where I
step back yeah I thought like something
had broken like a ligament had given out
or something like that I had no idea I
wish I wish I would have had the
hindsight to just not chase I mean I
have this thing where I love to hit
people and run at them and like go in
for the kill which is which has worked
very well for me in my career but in
that instance if I would just if I would
have either number one switched to
southpaw because I could push off of it
I just couldn't lift it so I wish I
would have switched to southpaw or I
would have just planted myself in the
middle of the cage and waited for him to
keep throwing kicks and I would have
kept him I mean I only one punch really
got landed in that entire fight and that
was me dropping know when when that
happened how long did it take before
your legs started working again I mean
it was scary man I mean two two weeks
later or seven days later I ran five
miles so seven days seven days that are
but for about three days I looked down
at my foot and my brain was telling me
to lift my foot and nothing was
happening man I thought it was it was a
scary time I mean I got you were
wondering whether or not you had
permanent nerve damage in your foot yeah
and I had I mean I got a great a great
staff around me I mean we my my manager
has hooked all of us up with the Sanford
Medical up in Sioux Falls South Dakota
dr. Reeves orthopedic surgeon dr. Troy
Gus neurosurgeon I went in there he just
said you just have you just have pinched
basically yeah basically a pinched nerve
whenever you did that and it just good
that is crazy I've never seen that
before yeah it was it was unfortunate it
was it was horrible you know but it was
just one of those things and that was my
yeah I'm on a six six out of seven and
that was my one loss so yeah that was a
weird one too because it was a fight
where you know it was kind of just
getting going
mm-hm and oh yeah when your foot started
doing that I remember watching it going
whoa is his ankle broke look what's
going on here this is weird I mean it's
one of those things too or you know I've
talked a big John about it I've talked
to her Dean about it I've talked to all
these guys I'm like man would you have
stopped that fight and then right
they're both like man it looked really
bad
you know it'll yeah bad but but you're
still up and you're conscious I still up
and conscious and I wasn't taking damage
well I I could imagine like you know I
mean what's his name
O'Malley hurt his foot and he was like
he couldn't even walk and he was up
falling down and he was about to start
getting beat up like I was still on my
feet I was still fighting did it look
really bad that looked like a wounded
deer out in the middle of field you know
like of course but you know I always say
like if this was back in the Viking days
and you know you chop one of my legs off
and it's me versus him to the battle of
the death I'm still one of that fight
tunes I have ten times out of ten so you
wish the fight kept going hundred
percent yeah it's a weird way to stop a
fight too when a guy's not taking damage
he's just got a leg that's not working
properly well and the problem was to you
know he almost he basically called
timeout and asked for the doctors to
come in once you've done that the fights
over I think I think the ref literally
thought you know he should have just
called the fight right your leg was
broken or something like what did it was
his thought process I guess and then and
then the doctors came in and then they
started feeling around and they're like
you know they're like right here I think
is tibias fractured I can feel the bone
I'm like doc I promise you just get out
of here let me
there's let me fight I got a current I
got a ank a calf cramp or something I
was like you don't just lying to him I
just get out of here let me let me go I
promise it's fine I don't feel a thing
it's not hurt good and then they stop
the fight then they pulled the stool to
pull the stool from me - so remember
that oh yeah that's right that was my
commissioner that was that was near
Catholic Commission at its best like
pull the stool then I fell in and then a
bunch of people were like hey man did
they call the fight because they hate
they thought you couldn't stand and I
said no I hope not because that would've
been very unfortunate because I fell on
national TV got Charlie Brown he felt
like all Three Stooges Moe Larry Curly
thanks for nothing doc yeah why did they
pull a stool it was I don't know I see
some mistake I think I stood up I think
I stood up I was like hey maybe if I get
the crowd into it maybe these guys will
get out here let the fight go so I like
stood up and I was like let's go you
know and I'm sitting on the stool and
I'm freaking looked at him just and I
was like you better hope they don't let
me off this stool boy so I'm gonna come
break your face you know and then I
stand up and then he guy pulls the stool
and then a second later I'm on my butt
now why didn't the rematch take place
and I asked for it in October I asked
for it in November I asked for it in
December and then finally I'm like man
this is stupid
I'm gonna go ahead and take a take a
fight against the scariest guy in the
lightweight division Yamauchi
and then then he got injured so then I
fought Brandon Gertz so it's like I've
never once pulled out of a fight I went
into many fights injured I've never once
not answered the call
I've always stepped up and have always
been the most exciting guy in Bellator
will forever be the most exciting guy in
Bellator